uh why don't we talk next to chris from
ocala is is it pronounced ocala or ocala
florida
hello yes that's you hey
david what's up yes it's uh ocala ocala
florida
we're got it what's going on
not much so uh first off i want to say
thank you um
for everything you do man i mean uh
beforehand uh before i even saw your
show i
i was having a bit of trouble finding
any uh left-leaning
um talk shows i i feel like i've been
more exposed to like the people
like uh ben shapiro or dave rubin and it
was really hard finding the opposite and
when i
delve into your channel i was able to uh
completely switched my views on
everything i mean what you said made a
lot of sense and everything and
uh i just want to say thank you for that
um
i i have a question about um uh
biden's age um the
wright has been pushing this propaganda
that uh he's too old in that
kamala harris is gonna take over and
everything and i know that's a bit of a
stretch but i mean at the same time i
recognize that
the guy is 78 years old um should i be
expecting
that something could happen in the near
future i mean i know that you said
before that wealthier people tend to
um live longer like with donald trump i
mean even though he's
uh severely obese i mean the guy's a
freaking whale
um he does have a lot of money so
it's expected that he'll live a rather
long lifespan
listen um joe so so you're absolutely
right that class
has a huge interaction with life
expectancy in the united states
but i don't know that it's that
different between multi-millionaires and
billionaires so joe but from the
standpoint of economic class joe biden
at this point
is a a wealthy guy and i don't think
that's really the issue
you do point out the risk factors uh
donald trump
is uh quite overweight joe biden is not
uh donald trump doesn't exercise we
regularly saw joe biden riding his bike
uh donald trump is proud of eating an
unhealthy diet as far as i know biden's
diet is healthier
but biden is a few years older here's
the reality um
when you look at actuarial tables for a
74 year old and a 78 year old
sure the 78 year old on average is more
likely to die in the next year than the
74 year old by a relatively small margin
uh but in both cases you're talking
about people who are in their mid to
late 70s so
whatever concerns you had about donald
trump along these lines
should be sort of similar about joe
biden and that maybe the country would
be better served having someone who's
not in their mid to late 70s but i don't
know about
you know if you were fine with trump's
age and health i don't
see it being dramatically different with
joe biden
right okay so i mean real like
realistically speaking i mean
i shouldn't really be expecting a
president harris anytime soon right i
mean
the guy's being taken care of listen
he's getting the best health care anyone
can get as president of the united
states
and the the problem is we can make
assessments about
what we expect from large populations
making predictions about any one
person's health is very difficult to do
and that that applies to any any
individual
right okay all right chris i'm gonna let
you go because your phone won't stop
buzzing in the background and it's kind
of getting to be a little bit irritating
to the audience so we're gonna we're
gonna go but i really do appreciate
hearing from you
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
s h masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other
protective gear for covid19 and they're
giving my audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over 150 dollars you can
get there
by going to davidpakman.com mask the
link is under this video
and you can save 20 on everything in
their store when you use the coupon code
david